love you I love you I love you like
never before
[Music]
the Grammys paid tribute to Loretta Lynn
Christine McVie take off and more with a
star studied in memoriam performance to
be able to honor Christine McVie who is
a good friend and it's one of my
favorite artists and Gone Too Soon so it
means a lot and my makeup artist said
waterproof I said definitely Casey
Musgraves honored Loretta Lynn singing
the late musician song Coal Miner's
Daughter
well I was born a cold
modern's daughter
cuevo remembered his fellow Migos member
and nephew takeoff
meanwhile Sheryl Crow Bonnie Raitt and
Mick Fleetwood performed for Christine
McVie who died in November it was very
lovely because Mick called me and said
this is the way I see it and we want it
to feel like it's a hymn and just to
speak with him who's had this incredibly
long beautiful relationship with this
woman just made it all really it's uh
it's a big moment I mean selfishly
privately it's a another
another step in closure for having lost
Chris so so recently and she was very
much like a sister to me a fellow band
member obviously in Fleetwood Mac and a
dear dear dear friend